En este video vamos a hablar sobre una unidad de
medida conocida como metro, que seguramente has
escuchado antes. Probablemente es la unidad
de longitud más usada en todo el mundo,
así que la pregunta natural es ¿cuánto mide
un metro? Bueno, una forma de tener una idea
aproximada de un metro es imaginar a un jugador
de basquetbol razonablemente alto, un poco más
alto que una persona de estatura promedio,
un poco más alto que yo que tengo una altura
promedio. Este es nuestro jugador de basquetbol y
él puede medir aproximadamente 2 metros de altura,
esta longitud será 2 metros, tenemos 1 metro,
la m minúscula es la abreviatura de metro,
y por acá tenemos 2 m. Otra forma de imaginar un
metro es dar un paso muy largo, si tienes entre
7 y 8 años y das un paso largo recorrerás cerca de
1 metro, este es el paso largo -justo aquí- que es
aproximadamente 1 metro, puede no ser exactamente
1 metro pero se acercará demasiado. Ahora bien,
existe una unidad de longitud relacionada al metro
conocida como centímetro, y podemos observar que
tiene la palabra "metro" en ella y también tiene
la palabra "centi". Ahora, tal vez ya conozcas
la palabra "centi"; 100 centavos hacen 1 dólar,
quizás conozcas la palabra "centena" que son 100
veces algo; entonces puede que te preguntes ¿un
centímetro representa 100 metros? Bueno, estaría
cerca y lejos con esta idea. Un centímetro no
representa 100 metros, no es mayor a 1 metro, de
hecho es mucho menor que 1 metro; 100 centímetros
será igual a 1 metro, es decir, si lo escribimos
abreviado es: 100 centímetros, c y m minúsculas
es la abreviatura para centímetros, entonces 100
cm = 1 m. Así que en estos dibujos que tenemos
aquí, 1 cm será mucho menor que el metro que
representamos aquí, incluso será más pequeño que
lo que acabo de dibujar. Para darte una idea de
cuánto mide 1 cm mira tu dedo: dependiendo de
qué tan largo sea tendrá aproximadamente 1 cm
de ancho. Yo soy un hombre adulto, de tamaño
promedio, mi dedo mide aproximadamente 2 cm de
ancho. Si tomamos mi dedo índice y tuviéramos que
medirlo, se aproximaría a los 2 cm. Entonces 100
cm hacen 1 m. Espero que esto tenga sentido para
ti. Con base en lo que acabamos de aprender sobre
metros y centímetros, pensemos con qué unidad es
mejor medir dependiendo del tamaño del objeto. Por
ejemplo, si observamos un árbol bastante grande,
¿con qué unidad sería mejor medirlo?, ¿elegiríamos
metros o centímetros? Pausa el video y piénsalo.
Bueno, un árbol bastante grande será incluso
mucho más alto que este jugador de basquetbol, así
que es más probable que las personas lo midan en
metros. Hay árboles que pueden medir 10 m o 20
m, incluso en algunos casos 30 m o más. Ahora,
¿qué pasaría si, en cambio, quisiéramos medir
un ratón? Este es mi mejor dibujo de un ratón:
aquí tenemos sus patas, parece un pez con cola,
pero supongamos que es un ratón. ¿Deberíamos
medirlo en metros o en centímetros? Bueno, un
ratón tiene una longitud mucho menor que un árbol,
así que lo más probable es que queramos medirlo
en centímetros. Un ratón pequeño puede medir 5 o
10 cm de longitud. Ahora veamos otro ejemplo donde
tengamos que decidir si medimos en centímetros o
metros. Digamos que asistimos al gimnasio local
donde hay una piscina; esta es el agua de la
piscina y queremos medir la longitud. Sabemos
que es 25 algo, ¿serán 25 m o 25 cm? Recuerda:
esta es la piscina de un gimnasio. Pausa el video
y responde: ¿crees que sean 25 cm o 25 m? Bueno,
como puedes imaginar, la longitud de una
piscina es mayor que la altura de un jugador de
basquetbol, muchos de ellos cabrían acostados uno
tras otro a lo largo de la piscina, por lo tanto,
esta es una piscina de 25 m de longitud; una
piscina de 25 cm probablemente tendría el tamaño
un teléfono celular, tal vez un poco más pequeña
o un poco más grande dependiendo del teléfono del
que estemos hablando, por lo tanto mediremos la
piscina de un gimnasio en metros. ¿Qué pasaría
si tenemos un edificio... Dibujemos un edificio
que tenga cuatro pisos, y alguien menciona que
mide 15 algo de alto, ¿serán 15 m o 15 cm de alto?
Bueno, si fueran 15 cm sería un edificio de lego,
un edificio de verdad tendría 15 m en este
escenario. Ahora, ¿qué pasará si pensamos
en la longitud de mi pulgar? Este es mi pulgar,
y la longitud de mi pulgar -por aquí-, sabemos
que es de 5 algo, esta longitud es de 5 algo,
¿serán 5 m o 5 cm?, ¿cuál crees que es? Bueno,
si fueran 5 m sería un gigante muy, muy, muy
grande, el largo de mi pulgar sería más del doble
de la altura de un jugador de basquetbol bastante
alto, por lo tanto, esta longitud es de 5 cm. Así
que espero que todo esto te dé una idea acerca de
los metros y centímetros. En Khan Academy puedes
practicar mucho más para que tengas más claro
cuándo una unidad es más apropiada que otra.